[Music]
from armies of dragons to tragic heroes
legions of balrogs massive wars foul
treachery
and a trio of super-powered gems that
make the one ring feel like your
great-grandmother's pearl necklace
here are the epic events that shaped the
first age of tolkien's middle earth
the first age comes on the heels of the
years of the lamps and the years of the
trees
the years of the lamps lasts for
millennia and finds the valar
the spirit guardians of middle earth
squaring off against the dark
lord morgoth whose second in command
sauron will be the scourge of the third
age
this world shaken conflict leads to the
years of the trees
which starts after the valor withdrawal
to the blessed realm
here two mighty glowing trees take turns
illuminating the continent
in the following millennia the elves
awaken for the first time
fearing for the safety of these new
creatures the valor
defeat and capture morgoth and encourage
the elves to come and live with them in
the west
many elves heed the call while others
remain in middle earth
the next few thousand years are a time
of peace
as morgoth serves a three age long
prison sentence
and the elves that went west flourish in
the blessed realm it's at this early
date that both galadriel and feyenoord
were born
with some help from shelob's distant
mother ungollient
morgoth destroys the two trees and
hightails it back to middle earth where
many of his servants
including sauron have been hiding on his
way out of the blessed realm
morgoth kills theoner's father and
steals the silmarils
artifacts even more sacred than the
light of aeorendel the silmarils are
jewels that contain the living light of
the destroyed trees
in the fallout from morgoth's betrayal
feannar rallies his elves known as the
noldor
and convinces most of them to disobey
the valor and leave the blessed realm to
reclaim the jewels
this rebellion is cast in disarray when
fanart convinces a loyal
subsection of his people to attack other
elves as they leave
seizing their boats to sail back across
the sea to middle earth
as fanner sails back to middle earth
with a handful of the noldor
the majority of the elves are left to
find their own way on foot
this group which includes galadriel
didn't participate in seizing the boats
they decide to head into the frozen
north and cross the water at a path
where the two continents are closer
together
roughly marking the beginning of the
first age the noldar elves arrive in
middle earth
this is also the moment when the valor
saddened by the rebellion of the elves
still showed their support for them
by launching the sun and the moon into
the sky to replace the light of the two
trees
in the eastern regions men awaken while
it will take centuries for them to make
their way to the elves they exist
and they'll eventually wander right into
the first stage action
out of the frying pan and into the fire
run led by feyenoord
the smaller group of noldor returned to
middle earth catching morgoth by
surprise
the villain has set up shop in his
fortress known as angband morgoth's seat
of power is even more foreboding than
sauron's
unprepared for an attack by the elves
morgoth's forces are decimated
despite morgoth's resounding defeat
feanor is mortally wounded by a balrok
a tough foe for even the mighty gandalf
after a 75-year pause in the battle
morgoth attacks again but like sauron
after him
faces defeat at the hands of the elves
emboldened the elves attack is mountain
fortress
known as the siege of angband the battle
lasts close to 400 years
as the siege of angband drags on the
elves that aren't fighting on the front
lines
establish the hidden cities of nagathron
and gondolin
this pair of fortress kingdoms becomes
crucial in holding off morgoth
while the primary focus of the first age
follows the noldor as they build cities
and battle with morgoth over the
silmarils
another branch of elvenkind is also
important known as the sindar or the
grey elves
they're the elven race of throndwheel
and his son
legolas initially the elves continued to
deal with occasional attacks from
morgoth's forces
two hundred years into the siege the
first dragon
glaurung ancestor to smaug appears
still young it doesn't take much for the
elves to send him scampering back to his
master
after this the long piece begins during
which morgoth
remains quiet and the elves remain
vigilant the long piece is a time of
great prosperity
and optimism believing that the
silmarils will soon be back in their
hands
the kingdoms of the elves thrive during
the long peace
men enter middle earth history wandering
in from the eastern lands
many of these men are seduced by morgoth
just as king theoden will fall under
sour and spell in lord of the rings
however three clans befriend the elves
and join their cause
these men are known as the adam or the
three houses
i am not mad the long piece ends when
morgoth
unexpectedly unleashes rivers of fire
from his mountain fortress
leading armies of orcs and balrogs a now
fully grown glaurung attacks the elves
known as the battle of sudden flame the
assault leaves the noldor
reeling while the battle of sudden flame
is a solid defeat for the forces of good
it does lead to two of the most epic
events in all of tolkien's
writings first the noldor king fingolfin
becomes so enraged that he rides to
angband to challenge the dark lord
morgoth to single combat
just as eowyn will one day face the
witch king alone
the duel is intense as the elf lord
dodges morgoth's deadly mace
and manages to wound him seven times
despite his valiant efforts the brave
fingalphan
dies by morgoth's hand nearly 20 years
after their initial defeat the elves
gather their forces and attack morgoth
in one final
massive bid for victory one of the most
glorious first
age battles the battle of unnumbered
tears leaves the elven armies in ruins
and morgoth virtually unchallenged in
middle earth
while the battle of unnumbered tears
makes morgoth the most powerful being on
the continent
that doesn't mean his enemies are
completely defeated the kingdoms of
nagathrond
gondolin and doriath remain well hidden
these kingdoms are reluctant to resist
the resurgent dark lord in the open
the elves never fully recover from the
battle of unnumbered tears
weak and divided they're slowly consumed
by the forces of darkness
morgoth discovers nagathrond and
gondolin
the first by stupidity and the second by
treachery and destroys them both
i will not stand down before any elf
not least this faithless woodland sprite
romance in tolkien's writing isn't
limited to aragorn and arwen
one of the author's most celebrated
first age epics
is a love story the tale of baron and
luthien begins when baron
a man escapes into the enchanted kingdom
of the durya
after his lands are devastated by the
battle of sudden flame
there he meets luthien the daughter of
the elf king
thingol and the two fall in love however
the king is appalled at the thought of
his daughter marrying a fugitive
and a mortal man he jokingly tells baron
that if he can personally get one of the
three silmarils from morgoth's iron
crown
and act even more daring than bilbo's
theft of the arkenstone
he can marry his daughter baron departs
on his quest
but soon finds that luthien has come to
help him side by side
the lovers travel to angband and steal a
silmaril
throughout the adventure luthien pulls
most of the weight with her magical
abilities
as they return home the great wolf
kakaroth who makes the hobbit's wargs
look like mere pups
steals the simmeral biting off baron's
hand in the process
eventually they hunt kakaroth down and
recover the jewel
but baron dies of his wounds grief
stricken
luthien also perishes their tragic
romance is so
moving that the couple is returned to
life luthien is made mortal
and the pair are allowed to return to
middle earth where they live for a while
longer together
an epic tragedy the tale of the children
of hurun is the story of a brave
chieftain of men captured during the
battle of unnumbered tears
morgeth in an act more cruel than even
anything conceived by the lord of the
rings witch king
tortures hurun hoping he will reveal the
location of the hidden city of gondolin
hurin is unyielding angered the dark
lord curses huron's family
and forces him to witness the
destruction of his wife and children
khuran's son turin is at first raised by
the elves in doria
but he flees after he accidentally kills
a mocking elf in a brawl
from there he launches into a heroic
career to rival that of the third ages
boromir
repeatedly he rises to glory only to
face utter ruin
turin heads to the hidden kingdom of
nagathrond where he convinces the elvish
leadership to fight in the open
leading to the utter destruction of the
cavernous underground realm
unfortunately glaurung the dragon
deceitful as the hobbit's smog
brainwashes both turin and his sister
ninio
under the dragon's enchantment the two
meet and not knowing they're related
marry and conceive a child eventually
turin kills glaurung
realizing what they've done the siblings
take their own lives
the third great epic of the first age is
the tale of arendelle
the mariner directly related to all
three of the houses of men
as well as the elves arendell is born in
gondolin and flees the city's
destruction as a child
escaping to the western shores of middle
earth where a group of exiles has
settled in the wake of morgoth's
resurgent power
arendelle marries elwynn the
granddaughter of baron and luthien
who herself will be the grandmother of
gondor's future queen
arwen the parents of elrond and his
brother elris
who begins the line of kings that leads
to aragorn
arendelle and elwing are a tolkien power
couple
arendelle becomes famous in his own
right when he builds a ship
and heads out in search of the blessed
realm eventually
elwyn joins him together they reached
the blessed realm and asked the valor to
return to middle earth and help their
relatives who were on the brink of
destruction
the guardians moved by personal
sacrifice forgive the elves
and respond to the call once the valor
receive arendelle's plea for aid
they gather a massive army and head to
middle-earth to face down morguth once
and for all
morgoth has grown even more powerful and
unlike his lieutenant sauron
doesn't need a magic ring to inflict his
will known as the war of wrath
the conflict that ensues makes the
battle of the five armies look like a
bar room brawl
elves men gods eagles dragons
balrogs and orcs enter the fray in an
all-out battle of good versus evil
morgoth's armies are powerful but
ultimately they can't overcome the host
from the blessed realm
facing a defeat is total as sauron's
future fall morgoth is dethroned and his
army's vanquished
however the fight is so intense that it
breaks the land causing a flood
as water rushes in the region is
completely submerged
this event creates the familiar map of
middle earth we know from the lord of
the rings
with the land sinking beneath their feet
most of the elves and valor
head back to the blessed realm however
many others
both good and evil choose to head east
here the first age ends and the second
age begins
and with it comes a new threat in the
form of margot's second in command
sauron who will prove to be an even more
powerful foe
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the lord of the rings are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one